all right
greatest show the greatest show on
television
well it's Friday so you know what that
means let's welcome tonight's guests her
pronouns are Smokey and the Bandit
co-host of the bottom line on Fox
Business David McDowell
he's not a guest we just found him
sleeping in the studio
westernrazor.com owner David Angelo
She's So Dope Hunter actually tried to
smoke her oh step Kennedy at Fox
Business Kennedy
and finally she's cool cruel and makes
old men drool Fox News contributor
before we get to some new stories it's
Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
I would never have watermelon in the
fridge what a waste of space I'd have
Gwyneth Paltrow's head all right it's
leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading these so if you
don't laugh I will fire somebody
good okay here we go on Thursday Elon
musk's three billion dollar SpaceX
rocket exploded during its first ever
test flight when asked what may have
gone wrong musk replied we probably made
a mistake christening it with Bud Light
[Applause]
I got a nod from David Angelo
the New York Department of Education
says complaints about inappropriate
behavior from teachers has increased by
two-thirds including sexual contact with
students in other news male attendance
is up 95 percent
a new study shows promise for treating
diseases with fecal transplants
but further research is required as a
government spokesman said we'll never
convince Americans to put untested into
their bodies
it's good
I do not think you need to bleep that
word right I think this is the tougher
this is where we break the seal don't
bleep that word and then blame me when
questioned about biological males
competing in girls Sports the Biden
Administration said they didn't want to
implement a one-size-fits-all policy for
student athletes especially when it
comes to jock straps
God bad memories of that huh
yeah last week
prosecutors have dropped charges against
Alec Baldwin in the death of a
cinematographer on his movie rust the
actor's already back on set and said
he's eager to resume shooting
the series finale of Star Trek Picard
imagine caring
it aired this week and it gave fans
everything they ever wanted except sex
with a real woman
a team of U.S scientists in New Mexico
are experimenting with dead birds by
turning them into flying drones
so don't look up or you might get a
battery in the eye
Mr Bush took another hit this week when
it was revealed they're Clydesdales are
only hung like regular horses
yeah huh yeah
Twitter has revoked its policy against
dead naming or referring to trans people
by their previous names which is great
news for everybody who insists on
calling me Susan
that'd be great in a new interview
former CNN host Brian stelter said he
has no idea why the network fired him
or why his pants keep shrinking
New York schools will now be banned from
using Native American mascots or a risk
losing State funding but several schools
say the offensive part is that they were
given something and are now asked being
asked to give it back
[Applause]
and finally a new study reveals that
there are numerous mysterious health
benefits to eating ice cream negating a
previous study that found that eating
ice cream makes you stupid
everything
all right
let's do some news
another Bright Idea from the Biden Rubes
crash test dummies with life-size boobs
yeah never mind the travel disasters are
numerous Crash Test Dummies have no
uterus
Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge is asking Congress for 20
million bucks to develop female Crash
Test Dummies
but hey the way women drive maybe all
Crash Test Dummies should be female
[Music]
it's offensive
so 20 million bucks what the hell will
that be spent on I mean this is a normal
crash test dummy see that here's the
modified dummy
and that that costs 20 million bucks a
dress
they say at five feet tall and 110
pounds the dummies match the size of an
average American Woman
yeah maybe in the 50s but that is way
different than a man I mean who would
have thought oh yeah normal people
and the plan is already getting support
from those in mayor Pete's party
you also plan to make important
Investments to address the roadway
safety crisis including the critical
funding that would accelerate the
development of the use of female
dummies in Crash testing this will start
to fight the gender inequity among
vehicle safety and crash victims
[Applause]
gender inequity among vehicle safety and
crash victims it's everywhere everywhere
but why not just speak English because
there is a difference according to this
chart from the national highway traffic
safety administration males make up a
majority of fatalities across every age
group
so which way does this gender inequity
actually flow
so mayor Pete in the Dems are actually
proving the point that we've been making
and they don't even know it that men and
women are inherently different no matter
no matter how much duct tape you slap on
your genitals before the swim meet
there's still significant differences in
body mass and muscle weight otherwise
why would there need to be female Crash
Test Dummies how stupid are they for not
seeing this
but here's hoping that they'll also be
adding a trans dummy
I believe we have the Prototype
comes in it's six feet two inches and
220 pounds but at least it will know how
to change the tire
and comes with two surgically implanted
airbags
David David David do you own a car
I do own I own two cars oh really what
are they a 1995 Nissan 300ZX with the
T-tops
and then what's your other car what's
your sports car
whoa uh 2017 Volkswagen Golf sports
wagon uh-huh the extra room in the back
oh for what anything it's practical yeah
why would you buy the normal one
Volkswagen let me do a commercial for
you guys
oh
and what would you say I would say
Volkswagen you know get one of these
things
[Laughter]
we don't need to over complicate
commercials do you think this is
you sell razors we get it you know um
we're female spokesman female Crash Test
Dummies uh wise investment of taxpayer
dollars I'm I'm so against this because
there are people who want these jobs you
know
I mean we have so many people
why are we giving them to enough with
the AI the robots
humans only as far as I'm
are taking the jobs of the humans you
are you you hit the nail on the head
exactly always a pointy in comment out
of me yeah
I don't know why you're selling razors
Dagan have you ever thought about this
before I mean it kind of actually makes
sense in a way the body differences but
it's not gender inequity the way they
Define it uh it's not and but I do love
the fact that these left-wing nuts and
these liberal politicians have tried
their level best to erase
real women yeah but you know we're chest
feeders
and uh birthing people but now when they
try to revive us yeah they do it
as inanimate mannequins that have no
genitals and and no reproductive organs
so good stuff no it's actually it's like
they're erasing real women but
preserving imitation women right I I do
think to David's right that real women
could do this rather than the mannequins
because we suffer from chronic pain
starting at the age of 13. I mean this
is this is obviously an absurd uh uh
hypothesis but when you look at medical
studies people volunteer for medical
studies in which they take a drug that
you know that there's a placebo group
and a non placebo group and people grow
a third eye yeah things like that why
not that why not this I don't want an
answer
I don't want to get in trouble Kennedy
is this an amazing story though yeah
this story can end it exist
independently while they vote down Title
IX no it's it's really the best thing
that I've ever seen number one if Title
IX goes away I'm fine with it because
UCLA will once again have a men's
gymnastics team and a men's swim team we
don't have that now because of Title IX
there are a lot of programs in the
country that are non-existent because of
that and now that gender is merely a
subject suggestion I'm good with that
but you're seeing this all wrong this is
not about the Democrats standing up for
women this is about Pete butterjudge
hating women so much he wants to put
them in cars and annihilate them all
right this is this is misogyny the
patriarchy is real and and he is their
president shame on you mayor Pete
you know cat I can't help but wonder
where are the dummies that reflect race
right where the black dummies don't say
Joy Reed
I mean the actual mannequin like with a
different skin color just so we know
everybody's included cat
no you haven't thought about it no I
just I also feel like the mail Crash
Test Dummies do represent my body quite
well
uh I just the government I mean the
amount of things they can figure out new
ways to spend money yeah is amazing I
want to know how this happened what was
going on in this meeting they're sitting
around they're like you know what
dummies Crash Test Dummies none of them
they don't have yeah
you're right okay let's spend 20 million
dollars on it I really want to know
where exactly does these 20 million go
exactly give me two balloons and a duct
tape and I can handle it yeah I
I understand what this has to be
something else really I mean I don't
understand how that costs 20 million
yeah what are they covering up
[Music]
it is great though it's the greatest
story look at
look at three boobies you know it's like
I've been to college campuses men are
the new women it's fine yeah yeah this I
smell filth this is just a bunch of guys
sitting around a room talking about jugs
yeah you know what it is
LMNOP some and they're going to want to
you know like we're we're going to want
to see these Dummies first and see what
they actually give them yeah it could be
really weird you know little inputs
little outputs I'm not I don't trust the
government all right I like the sound of
it yeah well you're a pervert that's
right that's why you're on fbn that's
what they said to keep the perverts on
fbn you Kudlow Stewart digging yeah
all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else